dear brothers and sisters there is a
clip that's been going around uh what
happened yesterday this day I was giving
down she approached me and you just
insulting swearing and you know trying
my best to control my anger trying my
best understanding especially when I
heard him he said that of course he
started to go to depression or something
like that so I want to understand they
might try my best then of course I'm
human being I'm Benny Adam I've lost it
literally I lost completely subhanallah
that day I mean yesterday but
alhamdulillah people have not put the
whole thing afterwards he came to me he
apologized alhamdulillah I spoke to him
and he admitted that he came
aggressively and he was wrong
alhamdulillah but one thing he mentioned
he said what happened his son he spoke
to me people start taking the clip from
the video and mocking his son that
caused his son to be depressed and and
even the school he goes to there's a lot
of sunnis
my dear brothers and sisters
please don't do that except someone
stopping stubborn from the misguided the
chorus is something goes but the Layman
you know because we wanted to be guided
we don't want him to to to cause them to
to move away
many people are not putting the whole
thing he came he apologized we processed
with each other we shook hands and it
was very respectful afterwards and he
took my number pictures numbers